is it possible that intelligence is just
statistics yeah
but what kind of statistics so
uh if you are asking the question
are the model of the world the models of
the world that we learn
do they have some notion of causality
yes
so if the criticism comes from people
who say
you know current machine learning system
don't care about causality which by the
way is wrong
uh
you know i agree with them yeah you
should you know your model of the world
should have your actions as one of your
of the inputs
and that will drive you to learn causal
models of the world where you know what
you know what uh intervention in the
world will cause what results or you can
do this by observation of other agents
acting in the world and
observing the effect
uh other humans for example so i think
you know at some level of description
intelligence is just statistics
but that doesn't mean you don't you
don't you know you won't have models
that have you know deep mechanistic
explanation for what goes on
uh the question is how do you learn them
that's that's the question i'm
interested in
uh because
you know a lot of people who actually
voice that criticism
say that those mechanistic model has to
have to come from someplace else they
have to come from human designers they
have to come from i don't know what and
obviously we learn them
or if we don't learn them as an
individual nature
learn them for us using evolution so
regardless of what you think those
processes have been learned somehow
so if you look at the the human brain
just like when we humans introspect
about how the brain works
it seems like when we think about what
is intelligence we think about
the high level stuff like the models
we've constructed concepts like
cognitive science like concepts of
memory
and reasoning module almost like these
high-level modules
is there's is this service a good
analogy
like are we ignoring
the uh
the dark matter the
the basic low-level mechanisms just like
we ignore the way the operating system
works we're just using the
uh the the high-level software we're
ignoring that
at the low level
the neural network might be doing
something like statistics
like me
sorry to use this word probably
incorrectly and crudely but doing this
kind of fill in the gap kind of learning
and just kind of updating the model
constantly in order to be able to
support the raw sensory information to
predict it and then adjust to the
prediction when it's wrong but like kyla
when we look at our brain at the high
level it feels like we're doing like
we're playing chess like
we're we're like playing with high level
concepts and we're stitching them
together and we're putting them into
long-term memory but really what's going
underneath
is something we're not able to
introspect which is this kind of
uh simple large neural network that's
just filling in the gaps right well okay
so there's a lot of questions there are
answers there okay so first of all
there's a whole school of thought in
neuroscience computational neuroscience
in particular
that likes the idea of predictive coding
which is really related to the idea i
was talking about in self-supervised
learning so everything is about
prediction the essence of intelligence
is the ability to predict
and everything the brain does is trying
to predict
uh predict everything from everything
else
okay and that's really sort of the
underlying principle if you want that
self-supervised learning is trying to
kind of reproduce this idea of
prediction that's kind of an essential
mechanism
of
task independent learning if you want
the next step is
what kind of intelligence are you
interested in reproducing and of course
you know we all think about you know
trying to reproduce sort of you know
high-level cognitive processes in humans
but like with machines we're not even at
the level of
even reproducing the
running processes in a in a cat brain
um you know the most intelligent or
intelligent systems don't don't have as
much common sense as as a house cat
so um how is it that cats learn and you
know cats don't do a whole lot of
reasoning they certainly have causal
models they certainly have
uh because you know many cats can figure
out like how they can act on the world
to get what they want um they certainly
have
a fantastic model of intuitive physics
certainly of the the the dynamics of
their own bodies but but also of praise
and things like that right so
um they they're they're pretty smart
they only do this with about 800 million
neurons
we are not anywhere close to reproducing
this kind of uh thing so to some extent
i i could i could say
let's not even worry about like the
high-level cognition
uh and kind of you know long-term
planning and reasoning that humans can
do until we figure out like you know can
we even reproduce what cats are doing
you